[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the break room everybody
it's a Wednesday we're thrilled to be
here this is the nerdy news show it
keeps you up to date on everything you
need to know live
from the new rockstars headquarters uh
we've got some really fun stuff to talk
about today yesterday my three
competitors did an awesome job of uh
reacting to analyzing the DC slate we're
gonna get more into that in fact we've
got some very interesting kind of takes
inside some updates on that we're also
today February 1st marks the beginning
of black history month and the first day
that black panther what kind of forever
is streaming on Disney Plus
final more on that more on that in a
moment with me to discuss that more
we've got Brandon Barrick hello Jessica
Clemens happy Black History Month yay
and Tommy bechtold hello everyone Zach
you asked the show jacket on or jack it
off and I said come on Zack it's always
jacket off for me
I get it okay I can't
um I've got a jacket on this is by the
way this is our uh Last of Us jacket uh
the actual jacket this is a jacket from
huckberry that Joel wears in the series
uh you can click the link in this
video's description grab one for
yourself uh it is an excellent jacket I
will say if it starts raining in the
studio I will be protected yeah uh it's
a waxed canvas they say uh but let's do
some headlines everybody let's get into
the headlines of the day oh baby
um our first headline this is a film
we're very excited about later this
summer we got a new poster for fast 10.
um I think we have the actual poster for
fast 10
ready to pull up again that movie there
it is look at it oh we're having a
little sound issues on time
um the the end of the road begins I'm
just glad that this this poster features
no cars uh and no action that's like a
very serious poster well it's probably
gonna have cars it's gonna happen but
like no one else gets to be on the floor
can you bring it back up again because
people are gonna drop oh do you think
well we'll see Jesus Christ drive a car
yeah oh that'd be fun or is somebody
gonna drive a car through a church
probably oh there's only one member left
of this family who's never raced
Jesus Christ what who's in do we know
who's who's going to be in it
Tyrese gives it is probably not uh Jason
Momoa no Paul Walker no ludicrous no no
Ludacris no ludicrous I don't know no I
bet the whole game
um Michelle Rodriguez yeah uh a reminder
is he alive in the universe still miss
their own yeah is in there somewhere
maybe John Cena Maybe
uh reminder fast 10 hits theaters on May
19th yeah that's coming up it'll be
kicking our summer off uh before
Mother's Day yes oh good speaking of the
family uh and they've been teasing uh I
saw they also released like the
releasing all these like throwback
images they released the an image of the
cast of the first
um movie from 2001 yeah two years crazy
since that first movie came out
um and they're they're teasing they're
gonna tease out all the movies in the 10
days leading up to the release of the
trailer
it has to be the longest franchise now
right
yes technically Indiana Jones still Pump
It Out technically yeah just because he
came back and it stops you know once uh
once Wicked comes out the Oz Cinematic
Universe
[Applause]
I mean if you count like uh The
Wizarding World there's eight of like
the Harry Potter movies that is true I
guess but fantastic Hobbs and Shaw too
so this will be the 11th movie well and
I guess that's fast furious just itself
without a spin-off has so many and has
been going on since 2001 that's it yeah
we're excited for the trailer it's
coming out on the 10th and we're very
excited for the film coming out in May
um other news Jedi Survivor uh EA's
Electronic Arts follow up Jedi phone
order has sadly been dis uh delayed six
weeks it was originally set to be
released mid-march it'll be coming out
late April you know what video games I
forgive you catch it up make it work
yeah don't have me Force levitating a
boulder that I can't place into the
holder over the shoulder or I'll be
furious okay fix fix the game don't make
me call my nephew at midnight three
o'clock east coast time to be like help
me solve this puzzle just fix it now we
don't want another cyberpunk and we
don't want another uh Pokemon and
everything is laggy as hell and I'm so
confused why I'm running but I'm walking
yeah yeah this is like this is the thing
with AAA games it seems like they make a
promise and then like they'll back it up
and even then on release day you still
get a 10 gigabyte update you have to
download for your game which is
frustrating I don't know I don't know
what the answer is to these things yes I
hope that they're making games better
and they're improving and movies get
pushed back that happens too I guess
you're just not going to wait because
that's what I tried doing with Pokemon I
was like I'm gonna give it a second I'm
gonna give it a second and then I bought
it and I was like it's still acting
weird
yeah I I'm all right with that Zach I
know we have another headline to go to
but before we do we we did miss one
thing I did want to let our viewers know
we haven't done a real gnarly super chat
in a while and uh you have been asking
for it I have been getting with my crew
I have what I like to call the darkness
Society it's me okay and a bunch of
other people that can't vote you guess
why hey hey and we are cooking up we are
cooking up something steamy for Friday
this week so I'm gonna tease it a little
bit tomorrow on what it just may be but
let's put it this way I'm asking
everybody to come on an empty stomach
you know what I'm saying dog uh just
like college and uh Friday is going to
be lit so save your shekels uh we
appreciate everyone super checking out
don't save them keep spending them now
come on you know
let that direct deposit hit Thursday
night at midnight and Friday get ready
to torture the brave four souls sitting
in these chairs I may call in sick
that's how sick this idea oh yeah we
haven't had a really gross uh redemption
in a minute so we decided we'll do one
on Friday uh Brandon's day off yeah I
will not be here I am doing this because
it's Brandon's day off and I want to
keep a friendship intact before
WrestleMania thank you uh oh and then uh
our our last big headline of the day
before we get into this DC uh news uh
Black Panther we're kind of forever as
we mentioned is on d uh Disney plus as
of today we're very excited we're
particularly excited because Jessica is
working on multiple pieces of content
but especially we're gonna be
re-breaking down the movie you know
we've been talking in the office the
volume of interviews news deleted scenes
updates that have come out since that
movie came out in theater like there's a
lot to get into right yeah and I yeah my
breakdown is specifically because Eric
did a great job doing the original
breakdown when the movie came out and
then he did 20 extra things missed so I
am only touching on things he hasn't
missed and unfortunately unfortunately
there's so much because the script came
out and they deleted a lot of things in
the script that would have done so much
the storyline plus the wakanda forever
podcast is a lot of interesting
information so it's a lot of me going
through the entire script going through
every interview and I'm really excited I
that I went in I've been awake since 4am
whoa
watching it but they put up the I think
the IMAX version is on yeah Disney plus
which is nice I love that they do that
now uh and I can't wait for like the
Blu-ray is coming out next week yes uh
which will have like all the deleted
scenes and like some of which they've
already released yeah they've released
some deleted scenes the IMAX version
like it uh you it's so clear first off
but like you also see there's so much
scripture in uh wakandan that is not
seen really when you go see it in
theaters but you're seeing it on the
Disney plus streaming one and I was like
oh my God I have to translate
when when could we tentatively expect to
see your re-brake town I shoot it
tomorrow
foreign
shop URL we only have a couple of these
left probably by the time Jessica's
video goes up and a couple people
watched it they might all be gone so
grab one ASAP as I said Black History
Month
I'm so proud of him uh hell yeah you
know what
um live every week like a shark week and
live every month like it's Black History
Month that's always been my motto okay
every song like it's Toyota
and every December make it a December to
remember uh where are the odds of Mark
do beware the Ides of March please uh
our main topic for today we wanted to
talk about this big DCU slate
announcement that we're waiting for last
month and it finally came out uh but we
were looking at it we were reading
between the lines yeah it's all the
holes yeah what's missing what's missing
in this picture you know I've always
said DC announcements are like jazz it's
the notes they don't that's right so
announcers they don't make that's right
you're a regular La La Land over there
Tommy let me tell you about jazz John
Legend ever since they gave me the
microphone
it's got pulled down in you I don't care
I was born in 2002. I hate you so an
interview came out today uh from Gizmodo
where they were talking with uh uh Jimmy
Gunn and Peter saffron and Gunn he was
talking about like the the 2023 DC
movies that we're expecting out this
year right he said quote I think we've
gotten lucky with the next four movies
frankly because we have Shazam which
leads into flash which resets everything
we've been guessing that for a while and
yesterday he was real hot on Fresh flash
said it was the best superhero movies
ever seen he's made two uh and then he's
made three he's made three we haven't
seen the third one it could be garbage
that's that's his Force oh Suicide Squad
in two Guardians Suicide Squad you're
right right oh uh yes uh so he then goes
into like a flash resets everything
which goes into Blue Beetle which is
totally disconnected is what he says uh
he says quote he can totally be a part
of the DCU uh and then that movie goes
into Aquaman which which leads into
Superman our first big project uh this
last sentence really caught me where
he's like uh Aquaman leads into Superman
yes now I don't think that that's
implying that anything in Aquaman 2 is
part of the new DCU or is it well we
know they had a Henry Cavill Cameo shot
that has now been removed from Aquaman
too we've heard we've heard couldn't
they shoot a new Cameo from a different
Superman and insert that into Aquaman
and the big thing to remember is Aquaman
2 was supposed to come out last December
and they pushed it a year and they're
purposely putting it after the flash
which makes me think whatever this flash
McGuffin is you know that Flashpoint or
whatever time travel else worlds
whatever they're gonna do in that movie
to basically set up a Multiverse for DCU
could play out in Aquaman in some way
where he's underwater and he's like and
there's like a portal that opens up and
then and then a new Superman comes out I
don't know I don't know like
whoever they're gonna cast as this new
Superman for Superman Legacy I mean do
you think it could be an Aquaman 2 and
some weird Cameo well this this is their
first feature as part of this plan right
they're we're getting an animated
Superman Legacy we're thinking it's the
first one he says it leads into it was
the first one that he kind of announced
in the order they didn't give dates for
a lot of these things it was kind of we
assumed so like and he's James said he's
already writing it or has written some
of it or all of it uh they've got to do
that casting pretty quick yeah right
yeah
until the movie comes out you don't even
know his gun's gonna tweet it well
wasn't it for a while there was a hot
little rumor that the kid from Euphoria
the place Nate was going to be Superman
Jacob yeah I mean he's a big
broad-shouldered man why couldn't he
play Super Tommy's starting a rumor
right now
lordy lordy it's a lordy I don't know I
don't know uh but guys you heard it here
first a scoop on the break room my
sources are telling me it's a lordy or
it's nothing
oh yes the singer Lord is also up for
them right she's never seen a diamond in
the sky uh
um one thing Gunn also said in this
article you know they brought up Gal
Gadot uh and he said quote she's up for
doing stuff which is very loose what
does that mean I have no idea uh she's
kind of down but you know I don't know
like that whole situation was kind of
weird before this announcement like they
Patty Jenkins submitted something they
said weren't they wasn't there like a
rumor that they were gonna like pursue
legal action I I don't know anything
about like any legal action it seemed
like that all ended on that was a bad
break yeah bad break between uh Patty
Jenkins and the previous Warner Brothers
Administration they're reading into the
gym yeah Administration yeah there was
all those rumors that like
there was Wikipedia articles being sent
back and forth there was stuff written
on legal pads no one knows right and
then James Gunn kind of squashed the
beef on Twitter and was like no we get
along look at this Wikipedia it was fine
uh so I don't know what this means for
Gaga though if they're just like they
don't want to say like oh she's never
coming back but maybe she will I don't
know if we're talking about holds in the
Slate there is no we have a thin mascara
prequel Series yeah but no other Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman as far as would it be
horrible if they treated her like they
did the uh laid it the older Wonder
Woman and just had her do a cameo
I don't know
she could play her mom she could play
hippolyta or whatever yeah then it would
be kind of I honestly if I was galgado
I'd be very irritated
uh this this article also pointed out
like this is not necessarily like the
order everything's everything they said
yesterday in that order is not
necessarily the order it's getting
released they've also made it clear
they've only like shared about half of
chapter one and that doesn't mean like
some of the stuff they haven't shared
doesn't fit into what they've already
done we've been speculating does half of
chapter one mean the first half of
chapter one or projects that will span
the length of chapter one they're just
gonna fill in twice as many things in
between you said two to three years
right so it's not like the ten year but
I do think he chose specifically the
major ones yeah could you see like
Flashpoint
resetting things so much and also
resetting flash because having a flash
is kind of important to me to the to the
DCU in my opinion but if they're not
going to move on with Ezra like they
could kind of have the new Flash ready
to rock and there could be an
announcement of a Flash movie that fits
into chapter one in my opinion well that
could be that could be the the ending of
The Flash movie right like right here's
a here's your new Flash I I have to go
back to my planet now
I've never seen forever again it's
interesting because Flash it does seem I
think I feel like he's more important
when we were watching what Justice
League was and now the new Justice
League especially now that we're
bringing in the Green Lanterns it's like
oh they're gonna create a new team and
maybe it's gonna be founded by someone
else that replaces yeah I think there's
gonna be a whole new world this is a
little world that hasn't known any thing
that happened in the DC EU I mean they
also made clear in this article that
like Henry Cavill and Ben Affleck
they're gone they're not coming back now
that could be a mislead a misdirect
we'll get to that in a second yeah uh
but but Henry Campbell and and Ben
Affleck they're done being their
characters and it also sounds like once
we're done with flash uh and Aquaman
we're probably done with them and it
sounds like and Cyborg is never coming
back so I mean that's it for Justice
League they have a chance no Patrol
wasn't so bad yeah we're gonna we're
gonna come back to that because I think
there there are some interesting
inferences we could make by again what's
not in that real quick we want to shout
out uh frequent uh chatter there Corey
kendrilli coming in saying penguin is
happening trust me now that one thing
that James again did not mention
yesterday no mention of this Penguin
Series right that we know there's been
multiple castings right we thought it
was already in production he didn't
mention it all as part of the elseworld
it's part of the Matt Reeves Universe
anything Corey can't really confirming I
believe Corey works on it I mean to the
best of our knowledge Corey our friend
is as an industry man and we and we we
take him at his word
perpetuating one of the all-time long
cons yeah I'm just kidding no Cory works
in the industry and has has some Insider
knowledge we don't want to blow up his
spot in case anyone that you know
employs him and again
Christina
Lots about the Penguin series because
they had nothing to announce yeah and
all they said about Batman 2 was that
it's called Batman 2 with Roman numerals
and here's well they gave the release
date they may not know for the series
with the release date it doesn't hurt
them to Slow Roll announcements About
elseworld's Properties especially
something like Matt Reeves that I think
DC fans that even though they're
clamoring for a focused DCU it's kind of
like we want to have our cake you need
the two we also want Matt rings to
continue making Batman material as long
as he wants to we don't want it to be
like oh just because it's else worlds
it's got to stop at the Batman too yeah
we're like no make the Batman 3 make the
penguin show make another Batman if you
want Batman Beyond go beyond the bat go
beyond it I would love a Batman Beyond
love that uh saffron also pointed out
when asked about like you know what's
the Cadence for these releases they're
saying about two movies a year and two
shows a year two series a year two
movies a year uh on HBO Max would be
which that's not too far
the Marvel Pace right now is three to
four movies a year and three series and
they worked up they worked up to that I
think the thing that also but that helps
with Marvel is that we're like even us
we're watching Disney so it's like when
Disney comes out with anything that's
Pixar or Star Wars or Marvel we have all
those watching and with DC I'm like this
is all we have I need more I need a
little bit of something and maybe I mean
maybe the Harley Quinn series falls
under like a different that's like yeah
it might align with a movie but not be
in this one and you know their whole
like two movies and two series a year
it's two movies not counting the else
worlds movies so you gotta Todd Phillips
Joker you gotta met Reese Batman maybe
uh Matt Reeves Batman series one a year
one every other year maybe so elseworlds
is basically like it's like spumcy but
like uh but uh the the penthouse version
of SpongeBob or even less connected
because I think yeah in this world
there's no chance Robert Pattinson ever
shows up in Booster Gold or Superman
Legacy or anything like that right right
whereas Spider-Man occasionally does
show up in an Avengers movie
occasionally when Sony allows it now
Jeff Schneider of that
uh he did mention that there is an actor
in talks for Booster Gold and James Gunn
was kind of inferring the same thing
yesterday in the interview uh but Snyder
also said quote uh James Gunn also has a
director on board for a top secret DC
movie that wasn't announced today that
director is notorious for taking his
time he did say his time and this
gendered
this is a scoop this is a scoop a rumor
a lot of them correctly come on the show
Jeff Schneider spill your spill your hot
mic juice all over the break room
anytime you want
um
uh this guy is going in in the office
because like okay a male director a
well-known one who's famous for taking
his time so is that Woody Allen Terrence
Malek
Gran Torino again and he did in 30 days
he wraps by 4 P.M every day so we can go
golf
um but it got us thinking about like oh
who would be some good candidates here
we threw out a couple names in the
office Edgar Wright I could see that I
think all right I did was last night in
SoHo yeah yeah and like I go right as
someone who was famously had was doing
an MCU project didn't like the control
he didn't have and kind of walked away
that was the original Ant-Man pin Reed
stepped in uh and he uh Edgar Wright had
like developed like test footage that
they they kept a lot of his elements in
the uh movie that we got I could see
like James Gunn and Edgar Ray having a
conversation of like I didn't like this
experience at Marvel
maybe I'm something of a person who
leaves Marvel myself
oh yes of course sorry it was a long
long worth it I'm not miked up today I
don't feel myself uh a couple other
names we threw out as director is kind
of famous for taking their time Quentin
Tarantino now he keeps talking about
retiring yeah I don't know that he wants
to step in he claims he's doing 10
movies and he's out and he's only got
one more left okay
now now he could produce a movie or
write a movie that wouldn't fall under
his rules of like I'm only doing
directing 10 movies and he also said he
didn't want to do a superhero movie also
they can't say the N word in any of
these movies
can't even say the f word which is
something he really means
ask Robert Patrick about his time on
Peacemaker I think they could oh yeah
that's true and each one landed like a
cinder block a couple other names of
directors we threw out I'm not talking
when the cameras are rolling by the way
get out of here we have there's no
evidence forever Patrick's joke for me
too guys no get out of here uh David
Fincher I like that I like he seems to
be pretty happy over at Netflix they're
kind of ticking up most of his time uh
Guillermo del Toro you know he he did
the hell boys he did the hell boys he
also did uh Pan's Labyrinth actually was
like pretty quick for him yeah and
actually I feel like he's actually
pretty productive you know he makes a
lot of stuff I also don't think uh he
works with it's like his stuff he's like
I'm the one that's gonna be writing it
I'm the one that made I'm not in a box
and a bunch of times well that's
stop-motion right yeah but that's kind
of that's like you know you do that off
on the side I feel like but and then
here's the name we came up with that I
think this is the showstopper okay a
well-known director famous for taking
his time
Mr Christopher Nolan bring him back
coming back
I'm not Reeves is the one
all right some honorable mentions what
do you guys think about Sorkin
um
Craven or Coppola
Derek said now that he
died
in the biz Alan Smithy is when a
director is so disgusted with their
project they demand to have their name
taken off of it the director is credited
as Alex look him up on IMDb it's a
hilarious thing and I do believe Alan
Smithy has been nominated for an Academy
Awards yeah the morbius director got
dangerously close to Allen Smith chat
pointed out like Sam Raimi he does take
a little bit of time to make a movie
Peter Jackson I mean I think any
director takes a little bit of time yeah
unless you're cleaning it's a weird
that's a weird Scoopy thing to say like
Spielberg makes well he makes two movies
every two years so one movie a year yeah
I don't know it's interesting also we
were joking that most of the directors
that take multiple years between
projects are just not good directors
nobody wants them to make any movies the
directors that do take over a long time
also write the project so they want the
best from it so they're like I'll change
an actor in the middle of it if I have
to I'll do anything
um some more some more interesting
things about this DC slate right Matt
Reeves is calling the Batman an epic
crime Saga this is a quote from him uh
which makes it feel more like a Trilogy
right if you have a part one and part
two probably a part three The Saga
implies more than two there's his uh
yeah
well also though if you're throwing
Series in between the film releases
at the same time they gotta cure that
McGregor's syndrome
is
oh yeah yeah he was sick in there
yeah because the actor was 102. uh James
mangled now is intoxic direct Swamp
Thing that's the word on the street
about it but now
um The Hollywood Reporter was kind of
running with this they weren't saying it
was confirmed but it was like he's in
talks to do it he tweeted about Swamp
Thing I think that's great you know uh
he's on a hot streak right now remember
Destiny
and a reminder his kind of previous
contributions to the superhero genre
Logan Logan one of the most universally
beloved uh kind of okay Leopold time
traveling
a horror comedy
Swamp Thing was did they say it was
gonna be comets or just like I basically
read today someone said comedy and I was
like oh did it change okay either way a
horror film that's Jessica confirming a
scoop Swamp Thing is going to be a
straight comedy I I think there's some
speculation this could be one of the
elseworlds things this could be kind of
like unconnected I don't know if that's
true it doesn't feel like they would
that's fine with that I just wanted to
be like like Tommy said yesterday I want
him to rip someone's arm off and so I
want to see James be able to direct
something I think we'll see that I saw
somebody in the chat yesterday was
asking
um which of these movies is the best
chance to be rated like heavier than
PG-13 it feels like swamp things yeah
if they make you 30 almost like the boys
where they're like these are people that
like what's that I said in a butt yeah
no further comment uh
DC has made two more R-rated movies than
Marvel has right at least the MCU has in
uh The Suicide Squad was rated R and
Joker was rated on it right like they're
not afraid to go there uh James got also
said in the interview that uh flash
director Andy muschetti is quote going
to be doing some more stuff for us which
that's another thing we were talking
about in the office all the praise that
is getting heaped on this Flash movie
people saying it's like the best DC
movie ever it's the best uh superhero
movie in a long time like yeah lock that
dude up get him doing a bunch of stuff
for you right yeah and it does feel like
it was also like hey sorry this movie
has become such a like a Bellwether for
you it's this thing and it gets delayed
and changed and there's always bad press
and we're not really going to talk about
it but we're gonna put it out and we're
not gonna tell people eat all that stuff
it does feel like uh hey sorry about all
that we'll make sure you get to do
another movie like this isn't gonna take
care of you on the other side yeah it's
not gonna take it down uh now one thing
we were kind of talking about when we
wanted to talk about on the show right
so gun and San Fran they've mostly
announced characters that aren't part of
this minor burst right we talked about
that apart from Superman and Batman
because if you're making DC movies you
gotta have Superman and Batman now there
none of these movies in the Slate is the
team up movie as far as we can tell so
what do you think will get a major like
Justice League character coming in
that's like Wonder Woman or Aquaman or
Flash or even some that weren't there
before like Martian Manhunter who wasn't
there until the Snyder cut or like
cyborg uh they're all long we just
didn't know yeah is it possible that
they are going to be part of one of
these movies that have already been
released or they're part of this like
secret movie that they haven't talked
about yet that's going to come out in
chapter one Justice League Legends
because I I don't think you're only
leading female superhero can be super
girl like just you can't go this long
without a dressing Wonder Woman No you
go I think it's going to be addressed or
sorta addressed in lanterns I think
that's a great idea of putting uh one of
the Green Lanterns in it it's just hard
because it's like it's two of them so
which one is going to be taken on the
mantle unless we have two Green Lanterns
on the Justice League team but I think
Supergirl could still be like the leader
the founding member of it and then make
the team out of those people yeah sorry
no no no no I mine was more of the next
uh uh the next character who I can't
forget oh the thing about the Aquaman
that's so confusing is we had that weird
Jason Momoa uh Instagram post where he
was like last time I left Warner
Brothers was when I got Aquaman and I
reacted like this whoa sorry I forgot to
put the microphone up to my mouth John
last time he did the thing that he was
like I celebrate Aquaman by by shrieking
he's like I just left a meeting with
James and Peter and this is my reaction
he went and there was these like bin
they said big things yet to come to me
that implies Aquaman and then and then
he also said he'll always be Aquaman if
you're like well that could just mean
like Aquaman's state of mind and the
friends you make along the way but I
think he's gonna be Aquaman in these
movies can I ask a question do we think
it's
um I it's so interesting seeing the
different reactions from different
members of the original Justice League
and how they're reacting to the news
clearly like Henry Cavill went to
Instagram with a long post Gal Gadot had
to come out with like a post Ben
Affleck's kind of like but like I'm
married to JLo I'm fine we own a Dunkin
Donuts so but Jason Momoa is like chill
about it we haven't really seen anything
from John Cena do you think it's because
those people got good news and they're
like I'm gonna keep quiet in my corner
doesn't it feel like with the exception
of a few previous Warner Brothers
Executives Jane's gonna put yourself
when they're out there glad handing
everybody right even the people they
have to give bad news to they're like
hey but we'll work with you further down
the road right like they're trying not
to dish out any bad news right and they
already knocked down you know we don't
know there's no more Black Adam stuff
but there was also no mention of like oh
we want to use the Rock and things too
because he when Black Adam too got
canceled he kind of said like I'm still
talking remember you know blah blah blah
but there was no mention of him
um but so if if they're building a new
Justice League which they've I think
they'll do at some point maybe it's not
called the Justice League maybe they'll
some other team up some team thing are
there other DC characters that you would
like to see be a part of this kind of
first chapter Gods and Monsters in the
DCU I would love to see Nightwing
personally oh I think Nightwing is a lot
of fun and they haven't really done it
uh in in the films yet I don't want them
on a team yet I want to buy himself by
himself I want as many things we can get
by himself and then he can join
Nightwing run he works in like Murder
Town or whatever it's called like it's
worse than Gotham City if you can
imagine that he's in like the bad
version of Gotham City uh there's also
Green Arrow right well so that's a big
thing right that's not a part of their
announcement any CW all right and I just
read the exception of flat I mean I
think canonically Green Arrow is dead
right in the CW verse he died at the end
of that they could bring him but he is
coming back for the final season of The
Flash in a key some sort of yeah maybe a
flashback right now they could bring
back Black Canary yeah
um
yeah that movie was canceled
characters all right like uh a big uh no
mention of a place where Harley Quinn
could show up yeah there was no mention
of Harley Quinn and you know no mention
of like another Suicide Squad movie
we'll obviously get this Waller show
which could feature anyone from The
Suicide Squad any surviving member
sorry Creature Commandos will have
weasels right my thoughts on the Harley
Quinn thing I have to think about it
from yesterday or this uh they have Lady
Gaga in the Joker movie who is gonna
play a version of Harley Quinn right
like they don't we think we think
there's that set and happening if they
don't have something concrete to
announce with that other iteration of
that character it doesn't make any sense
to overshadow Lady Gaga's casting and
being like Margot Robbie's still going
to be in it you know what I mean like
it's like announce it when it comes out
again another person's staying kind of
quiet about it because maybe they only
have good news that they you know it's
like you know she's also she's so busy
and I remember she was like one of the
main producers for birds of prey so
maybe she's just and not to be a bad
person just speculating the last two
movies she produced didn't do too hot so
maybe she's like I'm gonna step back a
minute sure make money for my company
pick a better scripts I mean she's
producing Barbie She's producing Barbie
okay so we got a chance Babylon and
Amsterdam were not good movies all right
first place like number one at the box
office
factors in both of those movies but I do
think one thing we can guarantee here
and this is no scoop
Barbie gonna smash hard
all the rest is it gonna smash
Oppenheimer which one's going to be
hotter oh I'll say this there's a
nuclear reaction in Oppenheimer and it's
not even going to come close to the Heat
come on the show see moo come on the
show Barbie uh there's of course also
you know things that consider like
Batgirl yeah and bad woman both uh I
mean projects that are no more great
after the kind of the bad taste uh
that's been left in everybody's mouth
kind of with that whole cancellation of
the Leslie Grace Batgirl film to
announce hey 2025 2026 yeah maybe maybe
with her playing it maybe somebody else
right I can see James Gunn allowing that
he's gonna like have her do a cameo and
then we'll be like oh my God our bad
girls here and then she'll get her movie
again is it gonna be like orc or is it a
cameo or is it a cameo like Krasinski
and a thing where it's like oh finally
although she way more deserves it no no
knock on John Christian get him go after
him no Krasinski so this is a safe space
for John K he's doing fine I think it
was uh I that's I think he's still
because uh when he auditioned so many
people for a rat Catcher And he stuck
with that rat catcher he was like I need
to make sure this woman is known by
every everybody for Suicide Squad and I
think he'll do the same thing for Leslie
uh for Batgirl because she deserves it
and God I just want her to have
everything now as we were and again I
think I think yesterday's announcement
was the Overture uh and Comic-Con will
be the big presentation of like here's
some casting news here's some more news
about chapter one all that now we up
until this moment we've only had the
crumbs that Jimmy Gunn was tweeting out
about our guesses for this lady there
were there were characters he tweeted
out that didn't show up in this slave
yes you know we didn't see dead man
right uh we did see he had tweeted out
that image of Batman and Tim Drake and
that came to fruition that came true
Damian Wayne
and he tweeted out a lobo image yeah
tweeted
he tweeted out a picture of Santa so is
this confirming that Santa's not gonna
be around next year Christmas is
canceled I don't know everyone now Focus
up say I believe in Santa just for
safekeeping I'm a child of divorce and I
need those two Christmases uh yeah we
now though him tweeting out those images
of characters
just because they're not maybe the Title
Character of the film doesn't mean they
couldn't show up in somebody else's
movie right certainly I think there's a
lot of petitions and one thing a couple
of things that we had talked about that
were not a part of the announcement
right this gestating uh producer John
swinging in what's the news Mike now
um one thing that was interesting from
this article that we didn't put in the
script is he said he said jismo will not
be playing two characters so he was like
begging to play Lobo he's still doing
Aquaman he said he won't be playing two
characters so does that like lead
Credence to the fact that we're gonna
get more Jason Momoa Aquaman
yeah yeah oh that's a good that could be
a good option or or the second another
Jason Momoa DC role is announced we know
Aquaman is dead we know he's dead I
can't wait for Aquaman to end with him
being like I'm not going back in the
water and then it doesn't go into space
and I'm gonna get bit by a vampire and
I'm gonna ride a motorcycle isn't that
what Lobos
he's a space vampire that rides a
motorcycle I love that oh we want him
Lobo
I don't know what I want to miss Momo
I want to miss Drogo as I was saying one
thing not mentioned this longest dating
Keanu Reeves Constantine sequel no
mention of that no mention of a Jonah
Hex project there was there was talk to
that like the uh the black Superman
project is still moving forward as far
as we know the kind of easy Coates and
Michael B Jordan I don't think it was
ever a green lip but it's still like in
development so that that could still be
coming up so we're saying no Jonah Hex
does that mean hex
is cursed okay possibly that was rough
that was rough other things now another
thing that was not in the announcement
today yesterday okay tell me and uh uh
we got confirmation today uh that little
series penny worth oh officially
canceled today
yeah
we found out last week right Doom Patrol
is finished Titan's is finished that's
done now when they were talking about
elseworlds like they did mention Teen
Titans Go yes like that's gonna it's
gonna go forever keep going they didn't
talk about the Harley Quinn cartoon no
but I assume that's still going
today special but I don't think that
that's been wildly popular for them
they're being very weird with their
animated stuff right now they're taking
Justice League off the platform uh they
have been really weird and I'm getting
nervous because Harley's got a lot of
seasons and then they got a special and
now I'm like okay
streaming platforms out there are
starting to cut shows Paramount pluses
merging with Showtime they're cutting
some shows off the platform this is
slightly off topic but it was also
announced today that Westworld one of
the HBO Max shows that not only got
canceled but removed from the platform
is gonna be on one of these fast
Services free ad supported television
Vision I think 3v and two like Pluto and
stuff like that my mom swears by Pluto
and tubing yeah and they're good and hey
if you can watch it somewhere and it's a
free service and you got to just sit
through a couple ads that's that's not
bad I don't mind sometimes the ads are
good because I need a little break you
know I can't take a happy that's when
you run to the fridge or the bathroom or
whatever I'm not trying to cats aren't
bad they keep actors employed I'm not
trying to be that person if it was a
different ad I'd be like oh okay but
it's usually playing the same lottery
ticket ad but I do watch it when I'm at
my mom's house because sometimes Pootie
Tang is on it and it's not anywhere else
and I need to watch it
I'm not doing Black History Month
not during blankets I almost walked off
the set yeah that's not great and that's
why you should go to nerd riot.shop to
get all the awesome merch we have here
at rockstars.com absolutely uh including
and and Tommy is ripping
we were just talking about this before
we started really how great that shirt
looks um we've walked outside in this
shirt
literally attacked
that kindness that's a reflection of our
neighborhood because we live in Manitoba
is what's known as the Moose district
and you do smell like corn cobs there's
that I make that noise when I'm outside
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum any
inspired Birch that you can get at
nerdrive.shop or newrockstarsmerch.com
uh if you can get them order it now get
it in time for the premiere uh uh in a
couple of weeks hey and if you're if we
happen to be at the same theater you're
at yeah during that Premiere and we see
you we see you repping it man we will we
will Spartan Kick you in there Jessica
will attack you I'll high five you'll be
great
well yeah you got to go to you got to go
to nerdwright.shop or new
rockstarsmerch.com either one I prefer
nerdrive.shop because it's a little more
deliberate can you know what else is
deliberate mandatory [__] oh no oh
right the segment so nice we play the
graphic just ones
change your face
today's top story Tom Brady quits
football like a loser
quick shout out since we're uh we didn't
Bridge the subject quick shout out to
our friend Christopher Myers who runs
crane brewing in Kansas City a big fan
of the show they sent us some some of
their delicious products before and uh
Kansas City the Chiefs are going to the
Super Bowl congratulations to you and
all the fine residents of Kansas City
yeah love your celebrations uh yeah
congratulations to you polling for you
rooting for you Kelsey Brothers the
first time two brothers have played the
Super Bowl is that true yeah first time
it's uh there's a great Step Brothers
meme with those two uh in their in their
sweaters anyway back to the DCU news uh
we got a lot of news here and we've had
some pretty I think yesterday's uh live
stream was very professional today's
episode's obviously been super
professional uh so I'm gonna give you
guys a chance to to give us your hot
takes your predictions you're out there
spins on what could happen unfortunately
and I do apologize for this I cannot be
here no for the segment what yes Tom
Brady and I were both we were double
booked Dr nasty was going to put a
python esophagus in I want to be able to
swallow things three times my size and
pass them through my body safely Dr
nasty said only one other man has ever
requested this Tom Brady but now that
he's retired he's been bumped to the
bottom of the list so I'm gonna get my
python my python throat uh because I am
the throat goat that's true now I will I
have found a replacement he's got he
needs about 13 to 30 seconds oh okay so
maybe we could read some super chats
while I go get my replacement okay
um uh Quentin's and then a couple super
chats and I would like to see a gen 13
Series in the DC slate well with the
authority coming in I think there's a
chance that like maybe kind of newer
introductions into the DC maybe like
slightly lesser-known groups could get a
shot that seems to be like James Gunn
thing too because you got to remember no
one was expecting the Guardians of the
Galaxy when that came out and that's the
project he wanted to do I think it's
smart for DC to lean into stuff maybe
people aren't as familiar with don't
have their own preconceived notions
about and let's see what what they could
do with that uh Benjamin Andrews thank
you for the Super Chat Sandy didn't
usually get to catch a show live but
glad I made it today we're glad you made
it yeah we are good we hope you still
have your job you still have work it's
just today you were able to do it uh uh
and Galactic Jay's saying Jason Walton
as Damian Wayne oh
so wet
yeah
what's up mother truckers it's time for
the hot mic podcast with me hot Mike oh
it's hot my body temperature is 134
degrees Fahrenheit that's why he's
sweating I got 99 problems but being
cool ain't one okay
for you on the on the mic podcast
my sons don't look me in the eye anymore
and that's a scoop
oh my God
I didn't check which one that was
how much this one has five heat
all right oh no how nice
I was told each one of you ice cubes
at the top of the pit was not the best
place that was not a good plan this
Show's unscripted we didn't gimmick that
hot sauce unpredictable
unbelievable we want to thank our
sponsor
Timmy's tongue blotters
when your tongue's too hot you gotta
take a trot Jimmy's tongue gliders
maybe in America
by children Dash was dying his eyes are
turning black like a shark uh how does
that does your throat did the dragonfly
Waters do the sponsor no the throat goat
at all well I was gonna make it work
he's drinking everyone's water it's
broke out as a separate company oh okay
okay
[Music]
podcast this is actual hot mic but he
runs a hot mic
um so my my hot take is this we were
talking about like what would be
something like kind of unexpected or
wild to come out of this I think just
based on they seem to be trying to move
themselves away from the kind of Snyder
verse as much as possible the characters
maybe the style the tone all this kind
of stuff I'm gonna say another way
they're gonna try to distance themselves
from the Snyder first I'm gonna say we
don't see any CGI villains oh in any of
these movies full face full face
villains absolutely maybe a little CGI
cleanup on concert yeah but no
steppenwolf-esque like full CG no no no
yeah maybe if much farther down the road
kind of like how we got uh Thanos uh
Josh Brolin kind of situation I'm gonna
say no CGI villains in this first wave
of films that's my hot take sexy that's
just in
my balls don't work anymore from too
much hot sauce come on that's a scoop
scoop
scooper Two Scoops thank goodness we're
not sponsored by a hot sauce otherwise
they wouldn't like that that scoop you
okay hot Mike
I just went into the future your eyes
took a little laugh I've seen the future
it's all flash movies oh okay but not
that guy oh I'm talking dicks out oh
okay
yeah yeah Flash movie I think hot Mike I
don't think Jessica likes you at all
like
all right Jessica what's your hot take
do I take the mic sure it's a hot mic
yeah okay
I think the flash is gonna die oh the
flash gets back he's gonna die and I
think he's gonna die by Damon Wayne when
he restructures the DCU I think Damon
Wayne is gonna kill the Flash in The
Flash movie yes he's gonna kill the
flash which this is gonna be horrible I
know but I need him to come in and we
bring in the CW Flash and that way the
flash stays in the DCU but we're not
dealing with this bad a lot of fans love
the the cw4 it's not even like a hot
take because I just want it really bad
and I think everybody else would want it
he's a good flash I like him I think we
I wanted Justice League where the flash
is there but I also want a really bad
Damon Wayne I want a horrible monster
Damon Wayne so I want him to somehow be
able to go through time and then come
across adult Damon Wayne who kills him
okay Damian Wayne not James with sorry
Damon Wayans uh who also might kill the
flash okay hear me out and live in color
Blake Bandit see you scoop made here
first I got a robot too I want the robot
I gotta take another sponsor J5 pickle
dance mystery barbecue sauce oh okay The
Taste is so good you'll wonder how do
they make that
is that the mystery how much hot sauce
are you I want everybody to know how
much this room smells like the hot sauce
there's gonna be another room that
smells like sauce tonight
okay and that's Mrs hot Mike's right hot
Mike we sleep in separate bedrooms not
Mike we haven't kissed in months oh my
gosh hot Mike you guys my sons don't
respect me no you can come back from
this it's been only a couple months I
got another scoop for you okay
the DCU will be entirely claymation oh
wow DCU have signed a massive deal
they've bought the rights to Burl ives's
bones oh okay we are going to reanimate
their lives I'm talking skin muscle
bone testes functioning heart
Burl Ives we'll have a Heartbeat by
2024.
I mean he voices that motion but not his
body the main point of the project is to
resurrect the skin bone flesh and
testing for our lives with a beating
heart but they only have the rights and
it's really cute mustache your little
button nose and beady eyes from years of
alcoholism
Our Lives will be back he's just are you
describing my mountain climber from I
can't stop talking or I have to
acknowledge the heat in my mouth I love
I love at the end of the movie Burl Ives
will be back
the skin bumps muscles
no eyes no eyeballs
here's my hot pink uh here's my outtake
for the GCU slate uh my hot tick is this
uh at the end of Batman the Brave and
the Bold is that where we're getting
that movie yeah it is Batman brave in
the Bold Batman will be dead I think
they're bringing back a Batman into the
DCU only to kill him off immediately
okay let's go night wing let's go every
other Bat character there is let's go
Batman now do you think that means that
Damian Wayne will kind of be playing the
Batman role or do you think that will I
think we could do like that I think you
could do like a Bruce Wayne is dead
another person is Batman type thing yeah
but let's kill Bruce Wayne that's enough
Bruce Wayne's too many Bruce Wayne I'm
glad you said that because I just got
another scoop okay
Batman's name's not gonna be Bruce Wayne
in the new movie what
now it's gonna be dick driver
I don't make the names up I can confirm
dick driver will be the name of Batman
who is your source for all this
I can't say but let's just say
rhymes with James fun
[Applause]
now it's time for my house
oh is that a Sriracha yeah it looks like
ketchup too you folks at home but that
is sriracha that's Sriracha which tastes
literally like cotton candy compared to
what I just put in my mouth earlier
you should do another one of those
just yeah it's hot again it's meated my
mouth is a furnace
in my butt you don't even want to know
it's cursed it's Jonah hext
pennyworth what was that it's gross it
made in three years penny worth it's
only worth a penny is that what you're
saying I don't know guys it's a hot mic
podcast okay
Ben Affleck will play Batman and Brave
them both oh we need a Batman that's
seen three robins die right that's what
you all keep saying on the internet too
Tommy Beck told my dear close friend who
has to read all these stupid tweets put
at him oh it can't be miles calories too
young three Batman three Robin's have to
die well guess what
what do we know about our Ben Affleck
Batman he's old one of his Robins is
already dead yeah yeah we've seen it
doesn't mean we could have a Nightwing
out there flying around somewhere
checking out all the strip clubs
and we can have Jason Todd or Kim Drake
either one maybe they're Bankers now
maybe they opened a friend a Krispy
Kreme franchise Damian Wayne comes in
the picture Ben Affleck has to leave is
Sweet Life with Jennifer Lopez and come
back and wear the cape everyone says
he's out but I don't believe it okay and
that's a scoop I can 100 confirm oh
that's a good Scoop thank you guys this
has been the hot Mike podcast it's me
hot Mike I want to thank all my friends
and sponsors uh both for substance and
alcohol abuse and literal sponsors oh
okay could not do this show without you
I want to thank uh Crispin Farms donkey
pepperoni frequent sponsor of the show
bunker Billy Button Factory making the
craziest buttons you've ever sewed or
pinned to your shirts and last and not
least I want to thank Satan whom which I
do everything in your name thank you
the Dark Prince thank you hot mine all
right if you guys don't mind I'll stay
and close out the show sure that's fine
I think Tommy has a pretty expensive
surgeries
like clear the restroom for a hot mic
he's coming I pray for our pipes folks
um well uh I think that's a good I think
that's a good place today don't you yeah
poor Jessica oh speaking of DC stuff
also Jessica's got a great video out on
the channel already it's definitely an
else worlds kind of story but there's a
Spotify podcast uh called Harley Quinn
and the Joker Harley Quinn and the Joker
Jessica did a breakdown of the first
three episodes uh people are really
enjoying you should check that out oh
Tommy hey Chris Tom my throat is so
enormous
egg in my throat Now give me your eggs
I don't understand why they couldn't
give both you and Tom Brady the surgery
because a Python's esophagus would be
super yeah
could you like unhinge your jaw like an
actual snake that's a cobra
so you've got to throw you've got a uh
uh python is having his from your from
your fangs to your bangs that's correct
I am the throat goat but I'm just a Jaws
law okay
also Tommy's gonna have a a breakdown of
the first six episodes of the bad batch
oh I'm suddenly healing let's talk about
that yes bad batch video coming out
first six apps Easter eggs favorite
moments guys check it out you demanded
it and as usual your boy delivered it
yeah thank you uh and be sure to check
out black panther we're kind of forever
now streaming on Disney plus let me
check out Jessica's re-break down of
that when it comes out next week uh so
much great content coming to the channel
it'll always be there for you thank you
all and of course our uh ongoing Last of
Us content Brandon and Jessica only with
Anna are going to be on that after show
dropping Sunday night very excited for
that yeah after that last episode oh God
I think it's all smiles from here on out
oh you think it's as dark as the show is
it's gonna pivot to slapstick comedy
from here on average I haven't finished
the game but I'm pretty sure it's pretty
funny style opening oh yeah whatever
happened to the cities in the world
they're all combined the buildings are
crashed into each other Pedro Pasco
uh but thank you for joining us today on
the break room we'll be back tomorrow
regular time 305 sharp uh we love you
come back Friday uh we're gonna get
gross maybe even grossier than this
maybe even grosser than that I can't
imagine it uh latest
bye
-bye
[Music]